opération mains propres pour la rectrice
et ses collégiens
c'est le premier geste barrière
indispensable qui est affiché partout et
répété en permanence aux élèves qui ont
bien retenu la leçon
cela beaucoup plus les mains les preuves
sont beaucoup plus attentifs sur les
chaises de précaution à la cantine cc et
surveiller son savent pas les mains on
se fait en soi peut reprendre et on nous
demande bien nous laver les mains les
habitudes avec les copains pour dire
bonjour notamment ou plutôt du coup
passé d'être un peu plus de temps à se
laver les mains et à prendre soin du
coup a à a pas infecter les autres et
après je fais infectés du coup par le
colis de 19 et juste à côté il y a même
un distributeur de gel hydroalcoolique
le gel a pu leur éviter la toujours été
nommé ce qu'on préconise avant tout
celle usage du salon à la fois pour des
raisons financières que pourrait tout à
fait naître des tensions sur
l'approvisionnement des jeunes donc la
liste au ce qu'on avait fait du stock en
fin d'année dernière bon combat mais
après on aura plus dont toute façon la
consigne est claire c'est le savons en
premier lieu et si l'approvisionnement
de saab ont fait défaut il a été demandé
aux proviseurs d'en faire la demande
urgemment pour se rapprocher du zéro
défaut ici le ménage est fait trois fois
par jour l'infirmerie doublé mais pour
le rectorat au delà de ces gestes de
prévention c'est surtout l'occasion de
montrer qu'en cas de fermeture
d'établissement tout était prêt pour
assurer le suivi pédagogique
on gagne du temps actuellement parce que
comme on y est née khademi assez
faiblement être impactés on se prépare
on pense des plombs de candy de
continuité notamment des plans de
continuité pédagogique
on bénéficie de l'expérience academy
beaucoup plus sévèrement touché près de
quatre semaines de cours sont déjà prêts
sur internet pour l'instant dans
l'académie seule une trentaine d'élèves
et de personnels sont confinés à leur
domicile